what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime operor
and today i will be talking about the
tragic complex
and beautifully frustrating relationship
between
aaron and mikasa in attack on titan
since the very beginning of the attack
on titan series fans have been debating
the relationship between the two of them
are they just friends slash family or is
there something more between them
something romantic and even if they do
have romantic feelings for each other
does their relationship have
any sort of future in the cruel and
unforgiving world
of attack on titan in this video i will
be taking a deep dive
into their relationship and their true
feelings for
each other and i will discuss whether
their potential romance
ever stood a chance in the attack on
titan world
if you enjoyed the attack on titan
content on this channel and you want us
to keep it going please leave a like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications by the way if you're
looking for some weekly anime podcast
content
definitely check out my podcast called
the rant cafe
anime podcast together with my friends
not stockwind briggs i make this podcast
every single week and we publish new
episodes every thursday
the rand cafe anime podcast is available
for free
only on spotify so check us out link
in the description finally this video
will contain
attack on titan manga spoilers seriously
i will be covering some major spoilers
from the very latest chapters of the
manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
aaron first meets mikasa under
terrifying and tragic circumstances
which is to be expected in the world of
attack on titan
aaron accompanies his father grisha to
the home of the ackerman family
but when they get there they realize
that mr and mrs ackerman have already
been killed by a group of ruthless
kidnappers
however their daughter mikasa is still
alive but the kidnappers are planning to
essentially
sell her into slavery luckily aaron
stumbles upon the place where mikasa was
being held
and he succeeds in killing two of the
kidnappers
but aaron is then surprised by a third
kidnapper since he didn't realize that
there were more
than two just when it looks like aaron
is about to be killed
aaron tells mikasa to fight in fact
these are the words that aaron uses when
he commands mikasa to fight against
the third kidnapper take him out fight
kill or be killed fight for your life
it's the only way the only way to live
is to fight these are the exact words
from the dubbed version of the anime by
the way
but i just thought that these words
ended up being so freaking prophetic for
how the story would eventually turn out
this is aaron when he was only 9 years
old and all of us manga readers know
how relevant those words ended up being
in the final arc of attack on titan
that is some crazy foreshadowing right
there anyway
after aaron says those words mikasa's
ackerman powers awaken
she is suddenly perfectly calm and
incredibly focused and her physical
strength
skyrockets mikasa is then able to
quickly kill the third kidnapper
and save aaron's life after that
aaron gives his red scarf to mikasa in
order to comfort her
and eventually the orphaned mikasa is
taken
in by aaron's family and she becomes his
adoptive sister
from this point onward aaron and mikasa
become extremely close
and they live a pretty normal childhood
until their home district is attacked by
the colossal and armored titans
that's when aaron loses both of his
parents and vows to get his revenge
on the titans which leads him and mikasa
to join the 104th
training corps and eventually become
scouts
now even though aaron and mikasa are
adoptive siblings so their closeness
could be the result of their family
connection
it is pretty clear from the beginning
that mikasa's feelings go beyond
just the normal affection for a sibling
mikasa has strong romantic feelings for
aaron
this is hinted at multiple times
throughout the story and it is then
finally confirmed
in chapter 138 of the manga in a very
dramatic way
but more on that later ever since aaron
first gave his red scarf to mikasa
she has cherished it dearly the scarf
soon becomes a symbol of mikasa's love
for aaron
and we've seen it used many times
throughout the story to convey
her feelings not only is mikasa
incredibly protective of aaron and
deeply devoted to him
but on multiple occasions throughout the
story mikasa is shown to blush
because of aaron in general mikasa is
not
the blushing type so aaron is pretty
much the only person over whom she has
been seen blushing
this may not be definitive evidence of
anything but it sure is a pretty big
clue that mikasa's feelings for aaron
are romantic
in nature so while i would personally
say that mikasa's love for aaron has
been apparent
all along the nature of aaron's feelings
towards mikasa
is a bit more complicated aaron
certainly cares a lot
about her but i think that in the case
of aaron it would be much easier to
argue that aaron's feelings for mikasa
stem from the fact that they are close
friends and adoptive siblings
one could reasonably argue that aaron's
feelings for mikasa are not
as obviously romantic in nature as
mikasa's feelings for aaron
and i know that all those aaron x
historia shippers would definitely make
that argument but with that said there
is one part of the manga that clearly
implies that aaron wanted something more
with mikasa something romantic in
chapter 123 of the manga
during the flashback that shows how the
scouts infiltrated marley during the
time skip
aaron asks mikasa outright why do you
concern yourself so
much with me is it because you were
saved by me as a child
or is it because we're family what am i
to you in this moment it is clear that
aaron is asking mikasa about the exact
nature
of her feelings towards him he is asking
her whether she just feels indebted to
him
whether she sees him as an adoptive
brother or whether she has romantic
feelings
mikasa then blushes big time and she is
clearly flustered by this question
she eventually says you are family and
then their private conversation
is interrupted aaron does seem a bit
disappointed that this is the answer
that mikasa gave
although it's hard to say because he was
distant and depressed during that
entire trip however if you are an air x
mikasa shipper
then this is the moment that you will
likely rely on as evidence that aaron
did want something more with mikasa if
that wasn't the case then why put mikas
on the spot like that in the first place
and of course chapter 138 is also a big
one for the erenex mikasa shippers but
again i'll talk more about that chapter
in a little bit
all in all the moment in which aaron
asks mikasa about her true feelings
towards him
opens the door for all sorts of
speculation
what exactly was aaron trying to
accomplish with this
question what answer was he fishing for
if mikasa had said that she loves him in
a romantic way
what would aaron have done would that
have affected his decision to initiate
the rumbling
in any way was he actually hoping that
mikasa would confess her love
and convince him not to go through with
his plan
there are so many unanswered questions
here and i really wish that mikasa had
the courage to confess her feelings
in that moment i think that mikasa ends
up feeling the same way because later on
in the story she also wonders what would
have happened
if she gave a different answer in that
crucial moment
but mikasa is extremely shy when it
comes to anything romantic
and the extreme blushing said it all in
my opinion but i guess aaron didn't take
the hint
after that exchange mika saneron's
relationship becomes a lot more distant
as
aaron begins to focus completely on his
master plan
his unilateral decision to kill all
those civilians in liberio
definitely shocked and disturbed mikasa
and this led her to wonder whether this
eren is even the same errand that she
has known
for all these years and as aaron
progresses further towards his brutal
endgame
he actively tries to push mikasa as far
away from him as possible
in chapter 112 of the manga aaron tells
mikasa that she only clings to him
because of her
ackermann genes the ackermann bloodline
is a byproduct of titan science
and over the centuries the ackermans
were specifically bred to protect
the royal family of eldea aaron claims
that when an ackerman awakens their
power
they begin obsessively clinging to and
trying to protect the person who caused
that awakening aaron suggests that he is
that person for mikasa because he caused
her to awaken to her power back when
they were fighting off those kidnappers
moreover aaron claims that mikasa is
just a slave
to her ackerman instincts and that she
obsessively clings to aaron not because
she really cares about him but because
she is forced to
by her ackermann blood aaron says that
he has always hated mikasa ever since
they were kids
because he could always tell that she
was a slave someone
incapable of being free but let's be
real
aaron says this just to put distance
between mikasa
and himself he wants mikasa to stop
caring about him
and to move on with her life because he
plans to initiate the rumbling and he
doesn't want mikasa to feel like she has
to share that burden
and that guilt with aaron in other words
what
aaron is saying here is total bs he
claims that this
info about the acronyms came from zeke
but we later learned that zeke did not
say this when aaron asked zeke why
mikasa is so attached to him
zeke told him that mikasa must just
really like him her devotion is not the
result of some ackerman instinct
as i said aaron said those horrible
things to mikasa because he thinks that
that is what's best for her
he wants her to stop worrying about him
and he wants her to move on with her
life without having to share the
crushing burden of what aaron was about
to do
and of course aaron is doomed to die
soon anyway because of the curse of emir
and he doesn't want mikasa to spend her
whole life crying over him
and this plan works at first mikasa
symbolically leaves her scarf behind
and decides that she will join the
anti-aaron alliance
she will do her best to stop aaron and
the rumbling before the world
is destroyed however mikasa still
doesn't want to kill
aaron she wants to get through to him
and convince him to just stop doing what
he's doing and go back to being the old
aaron that she knew
and loved she refuses to give up hope in
aaron even after he makes it explicitly
clear that he will not stop and that no
one can change
his mind it all finally comes to a head
in chapter
138 of the manga the second to last
chapter of the entire story as
every member of the anti-aaron alliance
is trying their best to stop aaron from
restarting the rumbling
mikasa experiences another painful
headache
at this point she is at her wit's end
she can't keep doing this
anymore she can't keep trying to kill
the man she loves
she just wants to go back back to the
home that she and aaron had shared
together and that is when mikasa
experiences a powerful
vision she and aaron are living alone
and peacefully
inside a remote cabin somewhere on the
island of paradise
this vision is like an alternate
timeline
where instead of initiating the rumbling
aaron decided to run away with mikasa
and live out the rest of his years
in peace in this alternate world aaron
tells mikasa that running away
is the only way for anyone to survive
which is the exact opposite of what he
said to mikasa back when they first
met in this alternate timeline mikasa
did confess her feelings to aaron
and it was her idea to just abandon
everything and run away together
aaron then hugs mikasa and tells her to
throw away his scarf when he is dead and
to just forget about him
he is destined to die soon because of
the curse of emir but she still has a
long life ahead of her and she should
just move on
and be happy but mikasa says that she
just
can't back in the real world she wraps
the scarf around her face
once again and she tells everyone that
aaron's body
is located inside his titan's mouth
she also vows that she will be the one
to take aaron
out but how did mikasa suddenly know
that aaron's body was
inside the titan's mouth it's likely
that this vision that mikasa saw
was more than just an illusion it was
likely a real connection between her and
aaron through the paths
a connection that was possibly
facilitated by emir fritz herself
it's likely that aaron told mikasa how
to stop him
and this is believable because as much
as aaron tried to pretend that he was
all in on the rumbling and that he was
determined to destroy the world there
were always clues that he was far more
conflicted
than he was letting on i mean the fact
that he allowed members of the
anti-aaron alliance to keep
using their titan powers against him
even though he could have stopped them
is the perfect example of this it's like
aaron wanted to be stopped or at least
some part of him did
so with the help of levi and armin
mikasa makes her way
inside of aaron's titan's mouth there
mikasa slices off aaron's head and then
proceeds to kiss him goodbye
as emir fritz looks on with a smile on
her face
wow what a moment what
a tragic love story as my brother goes
and pointed out in his review of chapter
138
tragically and ironically mikasa proves
once and for all that she really loved
aaron all along
by slicing off his head and stopping him
from destroying the world
if mikasa really had been just a slave
to her ackermann genes as erin claimed
then she never could have been able to
attack him and quite possibly
end his life but because she wasn't
really a slave
and because all of her devotion to aaron
up to this point was real
she was able to take that tragic step
and end
aaron's life even though all she ever
wanted was just to be with him
this moment was haunting and beautiful
and terrifying
all at once and it gave so much more
depth
and meaning to mikasa's entire character
and to the tragic relationship between
mikasa and aaron
it's hard to find the words to describe
the beauty and tragedy
of this love story for his entire life
aaron has been trying to do the right
thing
from risking his life to save mikasa
when they were both just children
to joining the survey corps in an
attempt to save humanity from the titans
to initiating the rumbling as the only
way to save his loved ones from the
hatred and violence of the outside world
in order to see his plan through to the
end aaron had to abandon his own
humanity
and he had to abandon his feelings for
mikasa armin and everyone else in his
life he decided to deliberately push
them all away
so that they wouldn't have to shoulder
the burden and the guilt of the rumbling
along with him he was determined to
shoulder that terrible burden
on his own but in the end aaron
seemingly chose mikasa
over his grand master plan and over his
own life
judging by what we know up to this point
aaron must have been the one who told
mikasa how to stop him
how else would she have known that his
body was inside the titan's mouth
and then mikasa did stop him proving
once and for all that her feelings for
him were real
always from the very beginning that is
truly powerful and beautiful
and also so damn sad but what else could
we expect from isayama and attack on
titan
now as of the making of this video there
is still one more chapter of the story
that is yet to come out
and amir fritz just standing there and
smiling in the final panel of chapter
138 was very interesting so who knows
what's going to happen
in the final chapter could emir use her
power to
undo some of the things that happened
since the rumbling began
or could she maybe use her power to
somehow keep aaron alive
now that aaron has proven that he loves
mikasa more than his own master plan
maybe amir will decide that it is time
for her to intervene
and guide the story towards a new less
tragic
path there is no way to know for sure so
we'll have to wait and see
but no matter what happens in the final
chapter the story of mikasa
and aaron is already one of the most
tragic and beautiful
love stories in anime and manga at least
in my opinion
let me know what you guys think did you
like the story of aaron and mikasa
up to this point and what do you think
is going to happen
in the final chapter is aaron really
dead or is amir fritz about to change
the game
don't forget to leave your feedback down
in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more attack on titan content here
on the channel please leave a like to
let me know it really does help
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications don't forget to
check out my weekly anime podcast
the rant cafe anime podcast available
for free
only on spotify you can just search for
rent cafe on spotify or click the link
in the description and in the pinned
comment
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
a quiet respect pate heffa liam thompson
algertol dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life tinel baked
buddhist and
tungsten tarkis finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers on
hell cruise anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kaylafond
rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted deadly saint matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]